[Music]
my producer is trying to get my
attention is that for sure
really this is crazy right now that's
insane
ladies and gentlemen this is amazing of
course we're all familiar with Aquaman
right okay yeah
I've just been told it's not I just been
told that Aquaman is about to spawn
right here
[Applause]
Behr's Aquaman king of the seven seas
monarch of the oceans she's swimming
around making sure the area is safe for
his mate this is fascinating
and here comes aqua woman woman here she
comes
she is clearly swollen with eggs lady
but after a brief courtship ritual where
they just sort of look at each other and
have a courtship ritual she releases her
eggs onto the sea floor while Aquaman
stands guard there she goes the eggs
have been released and now it's
Aquaman's turn he hovers over the eggs
I said he hovers over the egg and
carefully deposits his awkward sperm
[Applause]
overnight there you have it
well beautiful now unfortunately it's
just science the parents won't be around
to raise their young because surely
after mating they die off completing the
circle of life now we can't play the
song circle of life because Disney will
sue the pants off of us so we're going
to play a song called the oval of
existence
take it away Jimmy
[Music]
their dad everybody
standing on their children great show
tonight the cats and creators
[Applause]
[Music]
you